bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct au sommaire ce soir la fin du
suspense à l'Assemblée sur les retraites
il n'y aura pas de vote demain dans
l'hémicycle sur l'abrogation de la
réforme Yaël Brown privé a déclaré il
recevable l'amendement de la proposition
de loi liotte l'opposition et vent
debout ce soir elle va déposer une
motion de censure alors dans ce bras de
fer les parlementaires et le droit du
Parlement ont-ils été respectés face à
face plutôt grand débat à suivre dans un
instant sur ce plateau et puis un duel
dans cette émission ce soir sur un
scandale français les déserts médicaux
de députés ont décidé d'en finir avec la
pénurie de médecins dans les territoires
il défendent chacun leur proposition de
loi l'objectif et de même mais pas leur
solution face à face donc entre le
socialistes Guillaume Garraud et
Frédéric valent tout pour la majorité
enfin vos rendez-vous les partis pris de
nos affranchis et puis Bourbon Express
bien sûr à la fin de cette émission
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée voilà
pour le programme ça vous regarde c'est
maintenant
[Musique]
elle a donc tranché la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale à bloqué l'examen
de la mesure d'abrogation des 64 ans sur
les retraites au nom de l'article 40 de
la Constitution va y revenir dans le
détail cette mesure était à ses yeux
irrecevable il y aura donc jamais eu de
vote dans l'émission sur le report
contesté de l'âge de départ quelles
conséquences politiques va avoir cette
décision la séparation des pouvoirs
a-t-elle été respectée dans cette
affaire bonsoir Louis Marguerite bonsoir
et merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
député renaissance de Saône-et-Loire et
vous débattez ce soir avec Paul Molac
bonsoir et merci d'être là vous êtes
députés liotte du Morbihan je crois que
tout le monde a compris mais je le redis
quand même liberté indépendant outre-mer
et territoire à l'origine de cette
proposition doit d'abrogation des 64 ans
sur les retraites Paul Cassia bienvenue
bonsoir ravi de vous retrouver vous êtes
professeur de droit public à
l'Université Paris impensé au Sorbonne
l'article 40 même si on en parle
beaucoup ça mérite encore un décryptage
de votre part et puis ce soir Sarah
Legrain député la France insoumise
retenue dans l'hémicycle va nous
rejoindre dans un tout petit instant et
les filles qui réfléchit très
sérieusement à déposer une motion de
censure je vous propose d'abord de
rembobiner le fil de la journée la
décision dial Brown Pivet les réaction
il a 200 secondes c'est le chrono de
Blacko pour commencer
bonsoir mon cher Stéphane bonsoir ma
chère
alors cette décision franchement cette
décision c'est pas comme si on l'avait
pas vu venir je vous rappelle que fin
mai il y a une bonne privée avec déjà
annoncé que cette loi pour abroger la
réforme des retraites était il reçoit
donc la différence c'est que ce matin
elle était sur RMC et qu'elle l'a dit au
micro on écoute
sur ces amendements de rétablissement de
l'article 1 je suis très clair ils
seront déclarés irrecevables par
moi-même dans la journée aujourd'hui
on est un peu rodé maintenant comme mon
professeur les réactions les plus
vmandes qui ont immédiatement surgi sur
les réseaux sociaux venaient de la nupex
spécialement de les filles je vous ai
fait un petit florilège de l'agacement
très fort de ce matin on la qualifie la
présidente de Serville de garde-champs
ça c'est pour quatre nains de porte
flingue pour Rousseau vous voyez et même
de énième SBIR de Macron pour Mathilde
pano donc grosse colère du côté de elle
est fi notamment mais l'avantage c'est
que il y a le bon primaire avait déjà
répondu à ses objectifs le matin parce
que c'était fâché le même au micro de
RMC en expliquant qu'elle ne supportait
pas que elle est figure proche d'abroger
de d'empêcher plutôt du sujet recevable
qui propose d'un projet à la réforme
Bertha puisque à la demande de Mélenchon
le groupe et les filles datait de
l'obstruction pendant le débat dans
l'hémicycle pour ne pas voter l'article
7 donc voilà la colère il y a une
propriété
alors moi j'en ai marre de ces pompiers
Pyroman qui viennent nous expliquer
matin midi et soir que nous serions en
déni de démocratie alors que nous nous
appliquons la règle la loi et que nous
sommes constants et que eux utilisent
toutes les manœuvres possibles et
imaginables pour tromper les citoyens et
pour empêcher le vote on ne parle pas
seulement de la réforme des retraites ce
qui est motivé la proposition de loi
Eliott c'est aussi de défendre les
droits ou la rôle du Parlement qui a
tendance à se réduire par rapport au
gouvernement donc on va au moins une
fois dans l'hémicycle sur cette réforme
guerre très très résultats donc Bertrand
pencher était peut-être moins véhément
moins agressif si vous voulez que les
élus et les filles mais il était
peut-être encore plus sévère en l'écoute
et la failli à sa charge en faisant en
sorte de durablement affaiblir
l'Assemblée nationale et par conséquent
porter un coup très grave à la
séparation des pouvoirs en France qui
est le fondement même de toute
démocratie
alors vous l'aurez compris ce qu'on
reproche comme c'est une élue de la
majorité bien les soupçons sont est-ce
qu'elles n'auraient pas avantagé son
camp ce qui aura pas eu des pressions
que sais-je de Matignon peut-être encore
plus haut de l'église évidemment tout ça
est impossible à vérifier on peut quand
même remarquer que ce matin à la sortie
du Conseil des ministres Olivier Véran
était très bonne humeur on l'écoute le
groupe souhaite cette fois-ci redéposer
un amendement à 15 milliards d'euros par
an ce qui n'existe pas ce qui n'a jamais
existé et donc la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale rappelle qu'un
chat est un chat voilà et donc qu'on
peut pas faire un amendement comme
celui-ci alors ce qui complique un petit
peu le débat là sur l'article 42 la
Constitution qui je vous rappelle permet
de juger ircevable d'une proposition loi
si elle ne contient pas dans son texte
les moyens de la financer le problème
c'est que tout le monde a tendance à
être un peu de mauvaise foi à droite
comme à gauche sur le sujet ce qui peut
arriver en politique donc je vous donne
deux exemples par exemple
Eric verte lui avait pris position pour
la suppression de l'article 40 au nom de
la liberté du Parlement vous pensez bien
qu'aujourd'hui ça il y pense plus du
tout maintenant je trouve c'est très
bien l'article 40 mais du côté de
l'opposition on a tendance à dire
l'article 40 on ne l'utilise jamais ça
serait vraiment sans précédent alors
qu'on l'a quand même déjà utilisé 25
fois par exemple en 2001 sous le
gouvernement Jospin on a jugé donc une
proposition de loi de réforme des
retraites il recevable au nom de
l'article 40 et c'était donc les
socialistes qui avaient dit ça au nom
des comics donc voilà on en est donc le
débat va permettre à chacun j'espère de
se fixer un peu les esprits en attendant
pas de vote demain a priori sur cette
loi d'abrogation mais attention la
contre-attaque se prépare notamment du
côté des filles on écoute Mathilde de
panneau nous nous déposerons une motion
de censure parce qu'il est inacceptable
que on puisse faire un tel coup de force
sans qu'il y ait une réaction derrière
de la dignité même du Parlement alors je
vous rappelle que lors de la dernière
motion de censure il manquait neuf voix
pour inverser le gouvernement bon à
force et si l'émotion censure se succède
qui sait ce qui n'a pas une qui va finir
par atteindre son but on verra ça
évidemment dans les jours qui viennent
merci beaucoup Stéphane Louis Marguerite
je vais commencer avec vous finalement
une assemblée au suffrage un de sel ne
peut pas voter pour ou contre la réforme
des retraites est-ce que c'est pas ça
qui risque de rester dans l'esprit des
Français est-ce que c'est pas un peu
consternant finalement non mais ce qui
est consternant c'est que les mêmes qui
nous disent on aurait voulu voter on
déposé 20 000 amendements maintenant il
y a 6 mois et ce sont plein qu'après 14
heures de débat on les avait pas tous
excusés évidemment c'était c'était fait
pour cela je précise que le débat il a
été compliqué évidemment sur une réforme
qui est qui est difficile et on va pas
j'imagine qu'on viendra peut-être sur le
sur le fond de la réforme des Français
souhaitent un vote sur cette proposition
de loi c'est un sondage vous aviez
tellement heureux de nous perdre d'abord
et il y avait pas de sujet d'article
d'article 40 en l'espèce je vais venir
pourquoi pourquoi il y a un sujet une
question sur le vote la le premier point
c'est que d'abord on aurait pu voter
s'il y avait pas eu autant d'amendements
quand on a eu les deux semaines
d'examens national deuxième élément il y
a eu la vote sur la motion de censure
qui dépasse d'ailleurs l'enjeu des
retrait parce que c'est le gouvernement
qui met en jeu sa légitimité et son
existence donc on peut pas dire
adhésion
juste après
juste après l'application du 49-3 est ce
qui est d'ailleurs le pendant on peut
dire 43 on peut le contester il est dans
la Constitution mais il a son pendant
que cette motion censure et par ailleurs
il y a eu un vote en commission des
affaires sociales je sais qu'il est
contesté je sais pas pour quelle raison
d'ailleurs mais il y a eu quand même en
commission des affaires sociales
je précise que c'est très compliqué pour
nettoyer les spectateurs donc ce vote en
commission des affaires sociales sur
l'article 1 à acheter par voie
majoritaire de la suppression de cet
article qui visait à Broger cette cette
reportage poursuivez simplement et
simplement je voudrais juste rajouter
que au-delà du fond on peut combattre la
réforme très durement elle a été
durement combattue par certains par
certains ça peut entendre mais si
l'article 40 on considère qu'il n'existe
pas aucune n'existe plus ou qui n'aurait
pas vocation à s'appliquer en fait ça
voudrait dire que on pourrait on
pourrait contester n'importe quelle loi
et n'importe quel budget le budget c'est
quand même quelque chose de assez
central quel que soit son mode
d'adoption d'ailleurs ça veut dire que
immédiatement après on pourrait déposer
une proposition de loi sur lequel on
aurait aucun réglage financier aucune
recette qui viendrait qu'il viendrait et
donc ce sera un précédent donc
le droit c'est ce que vous dites ce soir
on va y revenir à cet article 40 parce
qu'il est central et c'est pas c'est pas
simple c'est technique pas le mot lac il
y a LeBron Pivet n'a fait qu'appliquer
la règle de droit l'article 40
cet amendement qui visait abroger les 64
ans crée une charge et donc était
inconstitutionnel c'est ce qu'elle dit
si elle était un constitutionnelle
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle PPL a été la
proposition de loi pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle a été adoptée par le Bureau de
l'Assemblée pour qu'elle soit discutée
donc il semble bien là qu'effectivement
il y ait une application une application
qui est à géométrie variable parce que
cette PPL qui a été proposée
elle a été validée par le Bureau de
l'Assemblée et maintenant on nous dit ah
il y a l'article 40 donc elle n'est plus
valable donc pour vous c'est de la
manière
et je trouve pour vous dire franchement
les choses je trouve dommage que ce soit
la présidente de notre assemblée qui
dans quelque chose qui est le président
penchère l'a dit mais dans une confusion
totale des pouvoirs qui finalement prend
les injonctions du gouvernement il y
avait d'autres façons importantes que
vous menez là pour vous elle n'a pas
pris sa décision en toute indépendance
qu'est-ce qui vous permet de le dire
très précisément
ça vous fait sourire en tout cas elle
n'était pas d'accord pour la prendre
puis elle le devient d'accord et il y a
quelque chose quand vous êtes président
de l'Assemblée vous voulez que
l'assemblée débatte c'est normal vous
êtes là pour protéger l'assemblée
le gouvernement donc la présidente
et en particulier il avait le vote
bloqué
donc c'était pas compliqué le
gouvernement veut cette loi très bien on
peut le comprendre il a ses raisons mais
c'est pas à la présidente de l'Assemblée
d'empêcher le débat d'accord
en tout cas c'est une présidence qui
visiblement ceux des jugent elle-même
puisque il faut le rappeler l'avait
rappeler elle a d'abord au sein du
bureau de l'Assemblée nationale jugé
recevable cette proposition de loi
ensuite c'est le président de la
commission des finances comme c'est la
règle
Eric Coquerel qui a jugé recevable cette
proposition loi en s'appuyant sur toute
la jurisprudence sur l'article 40 et sur
les propositions de loi des niches
d'opposition et c'est elle qui rend la
jurisprudence en jugeant finalement
irrecevable un amendement qui restitua
l'identique la proposition de loi
qu'elle a jugé recevable qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire d'abord elle se des juges
et si elle se dé jugée seule si c'était
seulement ça là malheureusement elle a
subi des pressions du gouvernement les
pressions d'Elizabeth borde qu'on a
entendu on qu'est-ce que vous permet de
dire retrouvez toutes les citations et
Isabelle borne Emmanuel Macron tout le
monde s'y met pour dire que la
proposition de loi est irrecevable elle
a subi ses pressions là mais elle ne
fait pas que ceux des juger elle ne fait
pas que retourner sa veste elle met en
péril nos institutions elle est censée
défendre le Parlement elle est censée
garantir elle ouvre la boîte de Pandore
pour vous qu'est-ce qui pourrait se
passer suite à cette décision pour bien
comprendre et ben je sais pas elle crée
une jurisprudence demandez justement au
concessionniste ça veut dire quoi que
les prochaines niches d'opposition
chacun des textes pour être jugé
irrecevable parce qu'il plairont pas
parce que c'est pas la bonne ou alors la
présidente pourra choisir quelle
opposition elle veut et puis même à
l'inverse les propositions qui sont
faites par la majorité qui sont pas des
projets de loi du gouvernement est-ce
que Eric Coquerel du coup pour aller
juger et recevoir ou devra les gérer ça
ou peut-être la présidente elle-même
devra en fonction de sa prose
jurisprudence juré jugé et recevable des
textes qui jusque là donc on vous la
séparation des pouvoirs et ça a été mise
en cause c'est que là ils sont vraiment
prêts à tout ils ont utilisé les
instruments de la 5ème République mais
là ils sont au bout même des instruments
de la 5ème République et de sa
jurisprudence et que tout ça c'est pour
imposer une réforme des retraites dont
personne ne veut dans le pays alors vous
allez répondre on va venir à l'article
40 on a même un sujet pour le Cassia
spécifiquement sur cet article Louis
Marguerite la mise en cause et forte ce
soir de la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale qui depuis le début on peut
pas dire qu'elle est spécialement
favorisée la majorité présidentielle
d'abord elle a sanctionné un certain
nombre de comportement qui venait de
tous les bancs tous les bandes de cette
assemblée elle a essayé au maximum de
donner la parole à tout le monde donc je
trouve ça très très beau procès mais
vous dites elle a impliqué une
jurisprudence mais même le président
Coquerel reconnaît qu'il faut appliquer
l'articarante avec souplesse mais pardon
le droit j'ai pas le souvenir que le
principe du reste il est sous prenant il
faut avoir un peu de souples créer une
nouvelle expérience
parce que quand on regarde les
jurisprudences sur cette question
d'abord sur tous les amendements qui
sont déposés depuis le début de cette
mandature il y en a eu 6000 qui ont été
déclarés il recevable au titre de
l'Artic 40 le président Coquerel le fait
tous les jours
s'il vous plaît c'est une chose de
déclarer recevable au nom de l'article
un amendement c'en est une autre de
déclarer ressemble une proposition de
loi ça demande une explication et on va
vous donner la parole Paul Cassia juste
après ce sujet qui nous permet de
prendre un peu de chant sur ce fameux
article 40 comment est-il utilisé
jusqu'à présent au Parlement c'est un
sujet d'Hélène Bonduelle regardez
l'article 40 de la Constitution est l'un
des rares à n'avoir jamais été modifiés
depuis 1958 il encadre financièrement
les dépôts d'amendement et les
propositions de loi des parlementaires
pour éviter de conduire à des dérives
coûteuses
ces amendements et propositions ne
peuvent pas être recevables si leur
adoption a pour conséquence une
diminution des ressources publiques ou
la création et l'aggravation d'une
charge publique en clair si le texte
génère une incidence budgétaire ou
fiscale c'est au parlementaire de
proposer un mode de financement on dit
qu'il doit gager sa proposition c'est
souvent une hausse sur les taxes du
tabac qui est proposé c'est le cas de la
PPL d'abrogation de la réforme des
retraites du groupe lot dans son article
les députés prévoit aussi à l'article 2
une conférence de financement du système
de retraite mais ce gage peut être jugé
insuffisant de manière manifeste cela
crée une charge pour l'État à hauteur de
18 milliards d'euros donc il n'y a pas
de doute sur le caractère il reçoit de
cette proposition de loi le contrôle
peut s'effectuer à tout moment de la
procédure législative par le Bureau de
l'Assemblée nationale la présidente du
Palais Bourbon ou par le président ou le
rapporteur de la commission des finances
il arrive aussi que cette charge
financière soit repérée mais tolérée et
qu'un texte soit quand même adopté si le
gouvernement décide de lever le gage on
s'aperçoit que depuis le début de cette
mandature 16e législature en un an il y
a eu six propositions loi qui comportait
un gage de charge comparable au stade de
leur dépôt qui ont été définitivement
adoptés et promulgués cette liste
contient là aussi quelques propositions
de loi qui entre guillemets impliquent
des dépenses assez fortes c'était le cas
de la proposition contre les violences
faites aux femmes ou encore de celles
visant à renforcer le droit à
l'avortement il y a donc la règle et
l'usage
voilà c'est la constitution et la lettre
et l'esprit Paul Cassia pour bien
comprendre
cet amendement
à cet article 1 supprimé est-il et
recevable au nom de l'article 40
je vais pas donner mon opinion
personnelle simplement présenter le
contexte dans laquelle il se trouve le
contexte est celui de l'article 40 et ça
a été dit dans votre portage cet article
40 il est curieux parce que il est
inchangé depuis 1958 et il trouve à
s'appliquer dans un contexte tout à fait
nouveau depuis 2009 où l'opposition a
des droits qui consiste à pouvoir
présenter comme c'est le cas demain des
propositions de loi c'est ce qu'on
appelle les niches parlementaires c'est
pas très joli niche mais c'est comme ça
qu'on les appelle et c'est niche
parlementaire doivent respecter
l'article 40 qui interdit aux député
d'aggraver les charges publics aussi
bien dans la proposition de loi
globalement que dans les amendements
pardonnez-moi mais là sur l'article 3 il
y a une augmentation de la taxe sur le
tabac donc il y a une compensation
financière prévue alors il y a pas
d'aggravation
on peut faire une lecture stricte ou
souple de l'article 40 et considérer la
proposition de loi dans son ensemble
dans son ensemble la proposition de loi
comporte en effet une aggravation des
charges publiques mais et il y a une
compensation est-ce que cette
compensation est exacte ou ça ça peut
entrer en débat mais il y a une
compensation c'est ce qu'on appelle
un gage comme ça a été dit par le
président Coquerel la proposition loi
prévoit un gage pour compenser
l'aggravation à la recherche publique
comment se fait-il que les propositions
de loi en moyenne soit recevable mais
les amendements à des articles de
proposition de loi sont très
régulièrement et recevables alors il y a
quand même une tradition je parle sur le
contrôle des parlementaires qui consiste
à faire preuve de souplesse dans
l'application l'artical pourquoi et
c'est important qui est cette souplesse
pourquoi parce que autrement les
prérogatives de l'opposition sont mis à
mal elles sont mises à mal aujourd'hui
dans cette mandature mais elles pourront
l'être aussi demain par jurisprudence
a été très attention à ce qui est fait
aujourd'hui parce que ça peut gâger pour
reprendre les termes désormais à la mode
ce qui se présentera demain dans une
configuration tout à fait différente
mais là c'est bien un amendement
l'article premier vous vous pouvez
rappeler tout à l'heure a été supprimé
dans le cadre de la commission des
Affaires
la difficulté réelle pour l'opposition
si demain c'était des articles 40 sur
des propositions de loi c'est ça le
risque oui effectivement ça rendrait la
tâche de l'opposition plus difficile
mais c'est aussi aussi le jeu de la
majorité que de la rendre plus difficile
donc il y a ici un rapport de force
politique qui s'installe sur
l'application verticale et qui en
quelque sorte assez légitime mais il
faut faire attention à ce que ce rapport
de force n'est pas des conséquences tout
à fait néfastes à l'avenir lesquels ça
pourrait lesquels c'est lesquels sont
simples et la tradition je pense sous le
contrôle des députés veut que l'article
soit appliqué avec souplesse dans le
cadre de la procédure parlementaire et
c'est important pourquoi parce qu'on le
voit aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de juge de
ce que va faire aujourd'hui madame la
présidentielle
discrétionnaire si l'amendement est
recevable ou pas et personne ne peut
outre passer
sa décision
ce point là mérite d'être examiné avec
attention on ne peut pas accepter qu'un
homme ou qu'une femme quelle que soit
son statut et des prérogatives aussi
importantes sans un contrôle or ce
contrôle de l'article 40 infini il
existe il y a un juge de paix de
l'article c'est le Conseil
constitutionnel si infini la proposition
de loi devait être adoptée par les deux
chambres et que les députés de la
majorité ou la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale ou la première ministre n'a
aucune chance d'être adoptée
méconnu tout au long de la procédure
parlementaire et bien il serait possible
de saisir le juge constitutionnel pour
qu'il tranche le débat ce qui veut dire
que avant dans la phase préalable il est
important que l'artica 40 soit
interprété avec souplesse pour que le
processus parlementaire pour que le
débat parclementaire pour que
l'expression pas très clair et merci de
ce point de pédagogie à vous entendre il
y a un risque qu'à l'avenir il ne soit
pas utilisé avec souplesse et à vous
entendre peut-être que j'interprète
c'est un peu le propos que j'ai tenu
juste avant sur des propositions de loi
qui faisaient peut-être quelques
millions d'euros quelques dizaines de
millions d'euros ça peut paraître
beaucoup pour les téléspectateurs mais
en fait c'est pas beaucoup c'est passé
pas un regard du montant global du
budget de la Nation et des comptes
sociaux mais mais là on est sur on est
sur quelque chose qui est 15 milliards
d'euros par an peut-être même un peu
plus on a un régime en régime de
croisière donc ça pose un vrai problème
de présence au-delà de la question c'est
bien compris on entend bien aussi que
sans cette nouvelle donne à l'Assemblée
si vous aviez une majorité absolue on
aurait pas ce déballage donc on est dans
l'inédit Sarah le grain donc vous
contestez la première décision prise par
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
vous dites aujourd'hui quel a eu tort de
d'abord juger recevable cette
proposition de loi ou alors comme elle
après 15 jours de pression du
gouvernement vous vous dites que
vraiment il faut tout faire pour
empêcher un vote qui devait avoir lieu
qui doit légalement avoir le pour le
respect des oppositions pour le respect
des sept Français sur 10 qui disent ce
vote doit avoir lieu quel que soit
d'ailleurs leurs opinions et en fait ce
que vous êtes en train de décider c'est
que quand le gouvernement a décidé que
quelque chose ne doit pas se discuter ou
de ne doit pas se voter au Parlement
alors il utilise tout y compris ce qui
est en dehors de la Constitution on a vu
le 49,3 le 47 1 le 44 2 le 44 3 on a eu
tous les articles conjugués ce qui
s'était d'ailleurs jamais vu et là il y
a une jurisprudence quelque chose qui
n'a encore jamais eu lieu à savoir un
article 40 utilisé sur un amendement qui
rétablit une proposition de loi qui
avait été d'abord jugé recevable par la
présidente elle-même donc vous feriez
mieux de reconnaître en réalité ce qu'a
dit Monsieur le constitutionnaliste ici
présent il s'agit d'un rapport de force
politique et dans ce rapport de force
politique votre
intention d'imposer coûte que coûte
cette réforme des retraites vous fait
piétiner piétiner nos institutions dans
notre pays et c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement grave vous constituez vous
considérez que le rapport de force
politique peut justifier derrière la
charge du Parlement et après vous
pourrez aller pleurer quand les gens
diront à quoi ça sert d'aller voter ou
quand ils iront trouver d'autres moyens
pour faire appliquer ce qu'ils veulent
vous allez répondre à cette charge la
question c'est est-ce que le Parlement
n'est pas un peu abîmé
aucune le soir ce bord de vous et ni de
vos collègues sur le comportement
la façon quand on a vu la façon dont ça
a été mené le débat sur la traite avec
les 20000 amendements ça n'a aucun sens
madame 20 000 abonnés
à quel moment on a manqué de respect de
la Constitution à ce moment-là par
exemple est-ce que le droit d'amendement
voyez-vous monsieur il est
constitutionnel et c'est vous qui l'avez
pas en commission des affaires sociales
la semaine dernière alors on va sortir
du face-à-face un instant Louis
Marguerite pour bien répondre à Sarah le
grand est-ce que finalement l'erreur
puisque j'essaye de comprendre votre
raisonnement une proposition de loi à 15
milliards elle elle était à 15 milliards
au moment du bureau de l'Assemblée qu'il
a déclaré recevable elle est toujours à
15 milliards aujourd'hui est-ce que
c'était une erreur de se réfugier
derrière ce bureau qui au préalable une
première fois la déclarait recevable
est-ce que vous vous comprenez que quand
on se penche sur le dossier de façon
très précise au-delà des convictions des
uns et des autres on voit des
contradictions
je vais pas dire qu'il y avait le bureau
il y a une question de bureau j'étais
pas dans ce bureau donc j'étais pas dans
le bureau de l'Assemblée ils ont ils
discutions
concret lui-même a dit qui d'ailleurs
déclare il reçoit d'article lorsqu'on
examine des lois de finances tous les
ans en tout cas on l'a fait dans le
cadre du projet de loi de finance tout
il a raison c'est son rôle il a dit il
faut savoir utiliser avec souplesse
c'était tellement souple qui on laisse
passer un gage de de 15 milliards
d'euros enfin soit disant à gage donc il
faudrait doubler les propositions
il faut remettre les choses en
perspective c'est un milliard par an sur
un budget des retraites de 365 milliards
par an donc déjà ça donne l'idée du
déficit c'est 15 milliards 15 à 20
milliards par an pour les retraites
et donc c'est quelque chose non on a
calculé c'est 0, quelque chose par an du
budget donc
des recettes des retraites mais l'argent
a trouvé dans la réforme c'est 15 donc
le gage qu'on a proposé il est
effectivement suffisant donc si on fait
ce genre de choses ça veut dire qu'à
chaque fois qu'une proposition de loi
déplairera au pouvoir donc c'est le
Parlement lui-même qui sont sur rat ses
propres parlementaires ça pose un
problème effectivement démocratique mais
comme le disait ma collègue
les
citoyens me le disent déjà à quoi vous
servez puisque de toute façon la
Cinquième République avantage on peut
dire outrageusement l'exécutif
l'ordre 3 le 47 ans là je disais que la
présidente n'avait pas besoin de le
faire puisque de toute façon le
gouvernement pouvait encore faire un
vote bloqué le vote bloqué c'est jeudi
voilà je choisis les articles je choisis
les amendements et Messieurs les Députés
vous votez le reste
cet épisode ce bras de fer platine en
faveur d'un changement institutionnel
pour renforcer les droits du Parlement
dans cette période où voilà il n'y a pas
de majorité absolue pourquoi pas
supprimer cet article 40 certains le
réclament chez les constitutionnalismes
mais pas seulement alors en général on
réclame la suppression d'article quand
on est dans l'opposition et puis quand
on est dans la majorité on réclame son
maintien ça a été dit entre les lignes
tout à l'heure dans le reportage
s'agissant s'agissant d'Eric verte qui
était par ailleurs président de la
commission des finances sous la
mandature précédente donc effectivement
il y a de quoi réfléchir à la rénovation
de nos institutions et je crois que la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale a
engagé un débat sur ce point la
difficulté ici c'est que il y a déjà eu
deux appréciations sur la recevabilité
de la proposition de loi une ça a été
dit par le bureau qui a accepté le dépôt
et une autre appréciation du président
de la commission des finances le
président Éric Coquerel qui a motivé je
l'ai lu ça m'a semblé je vais pas dire
convaincant mais en tout cas motivé
la recevabilité de la proposition alors
maintenant la balle est dans le camp de
la présidente de nationale mais on voit
que voilà ce jeu pas à l'intérieur du
Parlement je pense que pour le citoyen
pour la citoyen il est un peu compliqué
il est un peu compliqué et il plaide là
aussi pour une rénovation de nos
institutions moi je suis spécialiste de
droit je comprends ce qui se passe mais
je pense pas oui c'est compliqué je
crois qu'il doit y avoir un objectif
c'était celui qui avait énoncé le
président de la République il y a
quelques semaines c'était que un texte
aille au bout de son chemin démocratique
c'est ce qu'il avait dit pour la le
projet de loi de financement de qui
portait allongement de du temps de
travail de de l'âge de je crois que
c'est une bonne perspective pour tous
les textes y compris pour les
propositions de loi déposées par les par
les parlementaires d'opposition alors ce
débat s'achève on va parler ce qui peut
encore se passer demain il y aura pas de
vote mais vous allez nous dire un peu ce
que vous préparez chez les insoumis
juste sur les restitutions il y avait
une réforme en tout cas une discussion
en cours à la présidence
les Français qui nous regardent veulent
savoir la dernière fois le groupe lot
Elliott a failli faire tomber le
gouvernement à 9 fois près c'était fait
grâce à une motion transpartisane avec
la gauche les insoumis et le RN cette
fois-ci vous faites cause commune l'iode
et insoumis pour une censure commune ou
pas pour nous c'est pas encore décidé ce
que je dis simplement ce n'est pas
pareil de voter contre une loi que de
faire tomber un gouvernement ce n'est
pas le même acte et pour un certain
nombre d'entre nous moi je vois par
exemple c'était la première fois que je
faisais une motion de censure et que je
la votais donc on n'est pas forcément
parce qu'on sait très bien que les
conséquences ne sont pas les mêmes vous
prendrez la décision quand demain
ont déjà décidé d'en déposer pour
l'instant vous nous dites que tout est
bâclé on verra bien
du tout
à l'Assemblée demain sur cette question
ça me paraît important et ce qui me
paraît très important parce que
effectivement il y a un véritable
problème démocratique c'est quand la
population est contre quand les
syndicats sont contre donc les corps
intermédiaires et que l'assemblée ne
peut pas voter alors que l'assemblée
représente c'est article 24 de la
Constitution les Français oui ça pose
problème ça va laisser des traces pour
vous peut-être même avant les prochaines
échéances électorales en 2027 bon on
verra ça alors qu'est-ce qui va se
passer demain la balle est d'abord dans
le camp de la présidence jusqu'où
ira-t-elle est-ce qu'elle ira même
jusqu'à rejeter par exemple des
amendements qui parlent d'un objectif
de tourner à la retraite à 62 ans ce qui
serait alors là totalement
anticonstitutionnel selon selon les
informations de LCP c'est le donc
jusqu'où il aime les amendements
sa façon de se plier à la volonté d'un
monarque présidentiel vous avez parlé de
rénovation des institutions donc d'une
part elle dit qu'elle fait un groupe de
travail sur la rénovation des
institutions et d'autre part elle fait
une énorme publicité pour un changement
radical vers la 6e république
puisqu'elle nous démontre qu'on est dans
une monarchie présidentielle jusqu'où il
rappelle et jusqu'où la majorité
acceptera de dire que elle veut bien des
vôtres mais que jusqu'à ce qu'elle que
si elle les gagne et que quand elle les
perd il n'y a pas de vote et c'est ça la
logique du 49-3 donc nous on utilisera
absolument tout l'atmosphère de toute
façon on verra bien jusqu'où elle va de
toute façon ce sera un aveu de faiblesse
et on le montrera que c'est un aveu de
faiblesse on saisira toutes les
instances internationales qui sont en
capacité de juger dans quel état de
démocratie ou de non démocratie on est
dans le pays et puis on utilisera
absolument tous les outils qu'on a à
notre dispose c'est dit pour ne pas
laisser passer ce coup de force
absolument insupportable on va s'arrêter
là vous aurez encore le droit de réponse
parce que demain dès 9h et bien là ce
débat je ne sais plus comment l'appeler
des bas Parlement discussion peut-être
peut-être des votes sur certains
amendements on sera là sur LCP en direct
dès 9h dans l'hémicycle ce sera à suivre
avec Brigitte boucher et l'ensemble des
équipes de la Chaîne Parlementaire merci
beaucoup merci d'être venu en direct sur
ce plateau dans un quart d'heure
maintenant les parties pris de nos
affranchis ce soir Yannis roder revient
sur le défi des abayas qui se
multiplient dans plusieurs collèges et
lycées de France l'économie avec Thomas
l'estavel qui s'insurgent sur le cumul
des mandats dans le capitalisme n'est
plus dans Bourbon Express ce soir de
quoi on parle Stéphanie pierre et bien
on parle d'un budget colossal 413
milliards d'euros pour l'armée française
merci beaucoup à tout à l'heure les amis
mais d'abord on va accueillir deux
députés qui veulent en finir avec un
scandale français le manque cruel de
médecin sur le territoire les désert
médicaux touchent une commune sur trois
rendez-vous compte c'est près du 8
millions de personnes qui galèrent pour
se faire soigner alors faut-il les
obliger les médecins de ville et bien à
s'installer dans les zones où l'on
manque le plus de médecins Marco
polonais nous résume leur deux
propositions de loi avant d'accueillir
Guillaume Garraud et Frédéric Valtou
juste après
si on vous invite Guillaume Garraud et
Frédéric baltoux c'est pour un duel
alors ce soir rassurez-vous pas d'épée
ou de pistolet mais seulement des
arguments des idées pour lutter contre
les déserts médicaux vos remèdes
apparaissent bien différents et c'est
pourtant un débat crucial pour 8
millions de Français trouvaient un
médecin relève du parcours du combattant
je mets 1h15 pour venir voir mon médecin
sur place mais bon vu les contextes
actuels
Frédéric valtoux vous êtes député
horizon de Seine-et-Marne proche
d'Edouard Philippe quant à vous
Guillaume Garraud vous êtes député
socialiste et lu dans la Mayenne
troisième désert médical du pays cet
hiver vous avez lancé un tour de France
des déserts médicaux avec une
quarantaine de députés
issus de 9 groupes politiques de la
France insoumise aux républicains en
passant par la majorité des réunions
publiques aux quatre coins du pays pour
défendre une proposition phare la
régulation de l'installation des
médecins en fonction des besoins des
territoires autrement dit vous touchez à
la sacro-sainte liberté d'installation
des années que je me bats l'Assemblée
pour que on change les règles de
l'exercice et de l'installation de nos
médecins en France un point faible votre
proposition loi n'est même pas inscrite
à l'ordre du jour de l'assemblée à
l'inverse de la vôtre Frédéric valthoux
nous nous devons d'agir autant
rapidement qu'en cherchant l'efficacité
votre texte débattu en commission cette
semaine à le soutien du gouvernement de
votre côté pas question de régulation
vous voulez faire confiance aux acteurs
de terrain les professionnels de santé
les mers pour régler les problèmes
d'accès aux soins aujourd'hui notre
problème principal c'est le manque de
soignants si on crée des solutions qui
nous paraissent belles sur le papier qui
nous paraissent huilé théoriquement mais
qui n'emmène pas les professionnels
alors on n'aura pas réussi à régler le
problème de l'AC besoin parce qu'on aura
réussi qu'une chose c'est être dégoûté
et à détourner des professionnels qui
sont déjà pas assez nombreux pour
répondre à la demande deux propositions
loi pour un même combat alors on a une
question pour vous messieurs face à
l'urgence pourquoi avez-vous échoué à
vous mettre d'accord en voilà une
question pertinente bonsoir Frédéric
valtoux merci d'être là député horizon
de Seine-et-Marne c'est votre
proposition de loi soutenue par la
majorité qui est débattu en commission
cette semaine vous faites face ce soir à
Guillaume Garo bonsoir député socialiste
de la Mayenne votre proposition elle est
transpartisane puisqu'elle est soutenue
aussi par une petite partie voire une
bonne partie de la majorité qui soutient
aussi la vôtre donc la question de Marco
poliez elle est évidemment pertinente
pourquoi deux propositions le scandale
des désert médicaux ne méritent pas que
vous vous accordiez dans l'hémicycle ah
moi je considère qu'on n'a pas du tout
échoué à se mettre d'accord d'abord
parce que un
on a tous on a tous été élu locaux on
est tous élus de territoire qui
souffrent sur le plan médical et on sait
que les solutions elles sont
pragmatiques et que personne n'a la
baguette magique et donc c'est
simplement un dialogue un débat pour
essayer de trouver finalement les
solutions qui sont les plus efficaces
vous pourriez voter celle de Guillaume
Garraud
on s'entend sur plein de sujets et on
est d'accord sur plein de sujets il peut
y avoir dans les dispositions que les
uns les autres nous souhaitons certaines
dispositions et la régulation à
l'installation en études par exemple qui
nous différencie mais il y a pas de
toute façon
l'installation ça ne changerait pas le
sujet des médicaments
faut être très clair il s'agit d'obliger
les médecins à s'installer là où on
manque le plus de médecins non non c'est
pas ça c'est pas ça alors que c'est quoi
précisément
ce débat et votre émission pour juste
préciser les choses qu'est-ce que nous
entendons nous dans notre proposition de
loi transpartisanes c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a aujourd'hui plus plus de 200 députés
issus de tous les groupes républicains
de l'Assemblée ça va donner les filles
jusqu'à LR qui ont consigné cette
proposition de loi et qu'est-ce que nous
entendons par régulation une chose toute
simple nous disons à nos médecins aux
médecins écouter n'allez plus vous
installer là où les besoins de santé
sont déjà pour vous là où l'offre de
soins est correctement assurée comment
vous faites si vous les obligez pas et
bien je vais terminer mon raisonnement
n'allez plus vous installer ici mais
vous pourrez vous installer où vous
voulez ailleurs là où il y a des besoins
de santé donc on encadre en effet cette
liberté d'installation
l'encadre voilà on la régule c'est bien
le sens comme vous savez la régulation
madame Kawa elle existe pour toutes les
autres ou beaucoup d'autres professions
de santé les pharmaciens ne s'installent
pas exactement là où ils veulent il y a
des règles à respecter en fonction de ce
qu'on appelle un bassin de population du
nombre d'habitants nous proposons pour
les médecins une solution qui n'est pas
évidemment la même mais qui dans
l'esprit permet de dire ce qui compte
aujourd'hui c'est de répondre aux
besoins de santé la régulation elle se
freine dans votre proposition de loi par
les agences régionales de santé qui
regardent la carte il y a des zones
dotées d'ailleurs on va la regarder
cette carte des déserts médicaux sur des
sur la médecine générale c'est
intéressant parce que tout ce qui est
très clair en rose pâle c'est là où on
manque le plus de médecins on voit bien
que c'est pas uniquement les campagnes
c'est pas uniquement les zones rurales
l'Île-de-France cruellement de médecins
on est à 8 médecins pour pour 10000
habitants si c'est l'ARS qui décide ça
se passe comment
ça se passe sur la base d'une
cartographie on a vu une carte à
l'instant à l'écran ça signifie que et
d'ailleurs je suis heureux que nous
ayons pu le voter par amendement en
commission nous créons un indicateur
territorial de l'offre de soins ça veut
dire qu'on regarde bassin de vie après
bassin de vie territoire ville après
ville ce qu'il en est de la réalité de
l'offre de soins est-ce que on a
suffisamment de médecins généralistes
est-ce que on a suffisamment dermato ou
la cartographie une fois que l'ARS
décide d'envoyer un médecin là où on en
a le plus besoin s'ils ne le fait pas
qu'est-ce qui se passe je vous ai dit
l'inverse je viens de vous dire que on
autorisait pas l'installation là où les
besoins de santé sont déjà pourvus
ensuite ben voilà mais donc on dit au
médecin mais allez vous installer où
vous voulez ailleurs on l'a vu sur la
sur la carte à l'instant il y a des
zones qui sont en rose pâle d'autres ou
manifestement voilà
descends le dire à aller là où on en a
besoin et bien par les politiques
d'incitation les politiques d'incitation
qui existent déjà mais qui aujourd'hui
n'ont pas rempli leur office pourquoi
parce que quand on est un jeu de médecin
ou un médecin déjà expérimenté on va
exactement là où on a envie d'aller sans
tenir compte forcément des besoins de la
population et c'est ça que nous
remettons en cause il faut partir des
besoins de santé
alors partir du territoire regardez là
où on en manque le plus et faire en
sorte qu'on régule qu'on flèche et qu'on
incite c'est du bon sens non aujourd'hui
c'est le problème majeur mais priorité
des Français et des armées
à l'idée d'orienter les jeux de médecins
vers les zones effectivement où on a
besoin d'eux c'est logique et normal
quand on est médecin on est dans une
activité en plus qui est financée ou
solvabilité par la solidarité nationale
il est pas illégitime que la nation dise
à ceux qui sert un système qui est qui
le finance les objectifs qui sont les
siens et donc d'aller plutôt soigner de
remettre en cause cette liberté
d'installation là où on veut la liberté
d'installation bon d'accord mais pas à
tout prix le problème pour moi il est
pas là aujourd'hui le problème il est
que on est dans une période où on sait
qu'on a et on aura pendant les 5 à 10
prochaines années de moins en moins de
soignants et malheureusement des besoins
de soins qui vont aller en augmentant et
que parce que former des médecins c'est
dans le temps long que les courbes ne
vont pas s'inverser comme ça du jour au
lendemain et qu'à partir de là on doit
gérer pendant 5 à 10 ans la pénurie de
soignants dans les terrains
de remise en cause de cette liberté
regarder les pharmaciens c'est le cas
dans la fonction publique un jeune un
jeune diplômé du CAPES enseignant il va
dans les EPS pourquoi c'est pas au fond
le moment de le faire
qui a été discuté pendant pendant deux
jours de se focalisent pas que sur cette
affaire de l'installation
répartir mieux la rareté ça rendra
personne plus riche plus riche en
médecins et donc moi je veux bien qu'on
applique ce genre de méthode mais il
faudra expliquer aux Français que il
trouveront des résultats dans les 10 ans
qui viennent mais pas avant donc c'est
pour ça que j'ai essayé de faire de
mettre en avant un certain nombre de
propositions pour aider effectivement à
ce que par exemple sur la permanence des
soins l'idée de trouver plus facilement
un médecin en début de soirée le
week-end le
urgent les jours fériés oui pour les
soins urgents pour les les besoins
immédiats effectivement et bien on
puisse effectivement mieux faire
participer plus faire participer
l'ensemble des soignants
une garde par exemple à l'hôpital comme
on l'a fait pendant le covid
effectivement plus équitablement sur les
médecins de vie là aujourd'hui il y a 40
% des médecins généralistes qui
participent à la permanence des soins
d'ores et déjà donc dans les dans leur
cabinet il y a des cabinets qui sont
ouvert le week-end moi j'en connais il y
a des cabinets qui sont ouverts les
jours fériés c'est pas les plus nombreux
40% participent à la performance des
soins ça veut dire que la 60% d'autres
qui les regardent faire
la permanence des soins
et puis et puis jusqu'à présent on avait
aussi extrait de la permanence des soins
les cliniques et donc par notre
proposition loi et des dispositions
d'ailleurs qui a été voté je crois à
l'unanimité en tout cas de manière assez
large à la Commission
de demain les les techniques
participeront à la permanence des soins
c'est-à-dire dans ces périodes creuses
en dehors des ouvertures des horaires
classiques d'ouverture les cliniques et
bien seront susceptibles d'accueillir
les les urgences c'est-à-dire que quand
même blessés urgent
qui qui a ramassé par le SAMU au bord de
la dune accident de voiture mais pourra
être emmené dans un territoire dans sur
un plateau technique de clinique là où
aujourd'hui neuf fois sur 10 il est
emmené à l'hôpital et donc on soulagera
aussi les hôpitaux de cette charge qui
est la permanence il y a aussi besoin
des causes de la surcharge des hôpitaux
c'est vraiment le désert médical c'est
vraiment le manque de médecin de ville
ou de prise en charge ailleurs qu'à
l'hôpital sur ces deux points permanence
des soins et on met à contribution les
cliniques privées là vous êtes d'accord
bien sûr et d'ailleurs moi j'ai voté en
commission ces dispositions là mais ce
que je dis aussi à Frédéric valthou
c'est que il ne faut se priver d'aucune
solution
ne se priver d'aucun levier et la
régulation en est un je dis pas que
c'est la solution magique à tous nos
problèmes ce serait évidemment beaucoup
trop simple mais avec la coercition
est-ce qu'il y a des sanctions si les
ARS une fois qu'elles ont fléchés les
territoires voilà qui nécessitent à
envisager aussi bien évidemment mais
concrètement qu'est-ce que c'est ces
sanctions si ça marche pas on le regarde
dans le débat en effet nous allons nous
déposer nos amendements pour la séance
publique qui arrive à partir de lundi je
vous ai dit quel était le la démarche le
dispositif ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que on a besoin de ce dispositif
de régulation pour que tout le reste
fonctionne parce que depuis si on prend
un tout petit peu de recul depuis 20 ans
30 ans on a essayé beaucoup de
politiques d'incitation on a dit on va
faire des chèques alors on a fait des
chèques ce sont des aides et d'ailleurs
on a réussi en commission à faire en
sorte que
on limite le plafond des aides et que on
lutte contre les agents en incitant ça
ne suffit plus pour vous exactement il
faut il faut donc réguler pour que ça
permet au reste des mesures d'être
efficaces alors vous vous les connaissez
bien les médecins vous avez fait
quelques coups de griffes vous étiez le
président de la Fédération des hôpitaux
de France il y a un gros lobby des
médecins généralistes en France il est
même puissant à l'Assemblée quand on
vous touche je prends le terme de
régulation à cette liberté
d'installation immédiatement il y a des
menaces de représailles de
décontventionnement etc c'est pour ça
que vous vous êtes plutôt sur une
démarche de confiance et d'incitation
moi j'essaie de trouver un chemin de
pragmatisme c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
je suis intéressé par la régulation mais
je le redis à partir du moment où
effectivement il y aura suffisamment de
jeunes professionnels qui rentrent dans
la carrière pour réellement faire de la
régulation aujourd'hui 87% de la de la
France est un désert médical donc je
vous dis on rendra personne plus riche
en médecins
avant de les obliger un lobby médical
oui bien sûr on le voit sur la
négociation aujourd'hui
pardon mais aujourd'hui il y a une
déconnexion aussi de ce que
promuvent les syndicats de médecin
libéraux je parle des médecins libéraux
parce que quand on parle des médecins
les médecins hospitaliers comprennent
tout à fait le service de l'intérêt
général comprennent tout à fait
qu'effectivement il y a des modes
d'exercices et qui doivent répondre à
des attentes aussi de la Nation par
rapport à ce système de santé peut-être
on a été ces dernières années trop lâche
avec et pas assez courageux vis-à-vis du
médecine libérale qui a qu'on a pas aidé
à évoluer et qu'on a quand même parfois
conforté dans des modes de de de
d'exercice qui aujourd'hui peuvent les
mettre en décalage par rapport aux
attentes de la nation et donc il faut
arriver à les sortir d'un certain
individualisme et les jeunes générations
ne comprennent très bien n'évoque plus
leur avenir dans un exercice individuel
il faut arriver à leur faire comprendre
que voilà ils sont un petit prenant
d'une chaîne de prise en charge les
mentalités
vous avez juste des différences de
moyens pour y parvenir heureusement on
est d'accord sur l'objectif quand même à
savoir lutter contre les déserts
médicaux moi c'est un combat que que je
mène depuis plusieurs années et j'ai
acquis la conviction qu'on ne pouvait
pas s'en tenir aux solutions qui jusqu'à
présent ont été mises en oeuvre mais à
l'évidence ne sont pas il faut aller
plus fort
du volontarisme pour ceux qui nous
regardent c'est vraiment une priorité
pour les Français la question de l'accès
aux soins et de cette égalité d'accès
sur le territoire
qu'est-ce qui va se passer là vous allez
voter en partie c'est la semaine
prochaine dans l'hémicycle c'est ça
que les les articles proposés
recueilleront
plus tard sur la régulation
et chaque député prend ces
responsabilités et puis on verra
où ce qu'il en ressort
un amendement de gamegaro vous le
voterez
non j'ai dit que je le voterai pas j'ai
expliqué pourquoi
et je veux dire je ne sentirai pas je
n'aurais pas l'impression que mon projet
est totalement déstabilisé si si
l'amendement passe mais chacun votre an
responsabilité c'est intéressant
d'entendre de députés qui ont même
objectif qui voit les choses légèrement
différemment et pas si loin on verra ce
que ça donne et je vous propose de
revenir après après ce débat dans
l'hémicycle merci à vous on va terminer
avec les parties prix de nos affranchis
Yanis roder et ces histoires d'école
Thomas l'estavel pour l'économiste
Stéphanie des pierres on les accueille
tout de suite merci messieurs
allez installez-vous Yanis frauder qui
revient sur ses abayas qui se
multiplient dans les collèges lycée gros
gros fait du jour dans Le Parisien
Aujourd'hui Thomas l'estavel va parler
capitalisme mais cumule de mandat
préparez vos parties prive commence
comme chaque soir vous le savez par
Bourbon Express l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée nous est racontée ce soir
par Stéphanie Despierre bonsoir
Stéphanie
tu es obligé de vous interrompre on a un
problème de micro vous entend pas alors
ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va vous
donner un petit micro le voilà à
l'ancienne micro à l'ancienne avec un
fil exactement alors voilà vous nous
parlez de la loi de programmation
militaire qui a été adopté aujourd'hui
dans l'émission oui alors c'est
l'histoire d'un virage à 180 degrés
après des années à baisser le budget de
son armée et bien la France a débloqué
des moyens sans précédent pour les
militaires la guerre en Ukraine sur le
continent européen a servi
d'électrochocs les députés viennent donc
de voter
413 milliards d'euros en plus 413
milliards d'euros sur 6 ans c'est
colossal et historique selon le
gouvernement ça veut dire en fait qu'en
2030 les dépenses militaires seront le
double de celle de 2017 et ça c'est sans
compter l'aide militaire à l'Ukraine
alors cet argent servira à créer des
milliers de poste à acheter des
munitions des drones à moderniser notre
armement nucléaire il s'agit aussi
d'investir dans des nouveaux secteurs la
surveillance de l'espace les
cyberattaques et l'alo la loi prévoit
aussi de doubler le nombre de
réservistes oui alors cette loi de
programmation militaire et ce débat
c'est un beau contre-exemple à tout le
chahut qu'on a pu voir dans les Mexique
et oui alors que les couloirs de
l'Assemblée nationale notamment ces
derniers jours la tension est maximale
entre l'opposition et la majorité à
propos évidemment de cette proposition
de loi sur les retraites dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure et bien ça a été
l'inverse pour la loi de programmation
militaire on a parlé évidemment de
guerre de défense d'armes mais
paradoxalement l'hémicycle était un
oasis de paix et débats ont été très
apaisés pendant deux semaines et le
résultat du vote cet après-midi est sans
appel 408 voix pour 87 contre le
rassemblement national les républicains
et même le gros plus haute ont soutenu
le gouvernement et beaucoup même à
gauche on souligné l'esprit de concorde
de Sébastien Lecornu le ministre de la
Défense
vous devriez d'ailleurs monsieur le
ministre expliqué ce qu'est la
démocratie du parlementaire à vos
collègues Darmanin le maire du soft ou
autre Dupont-Moretti et si j'osais vous
devriez aussi donner des cours
particuliers à Madame borne je souhaite
remercier la capacité d'écoute et de
débats monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre vous nous avez écouté et vous
avez donné un avis favorable à une
vingtaine de nos amendements avec un
respect qui pourrait servir de modèle à
d'autres textes en ces temps de majorité
relative oui alors il y a quand même eu
quelques fois contre qui a voté contre
alors la France insoumise a voté contre
les communistes aussi c'étaient les plus
vindicatifs contre ce budget même s'il
ne conteste pas l'idée d'augmenter les
crédits
entre augmenter le budget des armées et
le doubler et demander en même temps des
efforts aux Français
investir dans un porte-avions alors
qu'il y a d'autres choix à faire
d'ailleurs les militaires l'ont dit
sur les 413 milliards
il y a le feu dans le pays pour 12
milliards donc excusez-moi du peu mais
enfin 10 milliards c'est pas rien c'est
pas une paille quand même
alors après ce vote la loi par au Sénat
le gouvernemental ou le sur une adoption
définitive pardon avant le 14 juillet
pour que le Président de la République
puisse l'annoncer le jour de la fête
nationale le défilé militaire bien sûr
merci beaucoup pour ce Bourbon Express
parfaitement clair on enchaîne avec vous
Yannis roder encore une affaire d'abaya
encore une affaire qui malmène le
principe de laïcité à l'école cette fois
c'est un lycée marseillais avec ses
tuniques portaient par les jeunes filles
oui ces abaya les voici Myriam il s'agit
de robe longue portée au Moyen-Orient
c'est une tradition là-bas mais c'est
aussi une tenue qui a été vampirisée en
réalité par les islamistes qui
l'encourage au nom d'une prétendue
pudeur ce qui a pour conséquence qu'elle
est aujourd'hui portée volontairement ou
non par des femmes qui obéissent à des
prescriptions religieuses radicales son
port a donc conduit le proviseur du
lycée Victor Hugo à Marseille n'a
appliqué la circulaire de la loi de 2004
appuyé par une autre circulaire de
novembre 2022 de ministres papendaye sur
les signes ostensibles religieux à
l'école qui dit que le port signe qui
conduit j'ouvre les guillemets à se
faire immédiatement reconnaître par son
appartenance religieuse et proscrit et
alors le proviseur a interdit ses abayas
il ne s'est pas fait que des amis
l'ambiance était électrique en fait il a
juste appliqué la loi et pourtant des
manifestations d'élèves ont lieu devant
le lycée pour protester contre je cite
un acharnement contre les élèves
musulmanes autre dimension du problème
indique Le Parisien ce matin des AED
vous avez l'équivalent des surveillants
en plusieurs fois déclenché des grèves
refusant de faire 10 styles je vois les
guillemets la police de la laïcité et
fustigeant les propos considérés comme
là encore j'ouvre les guillemets
islamophobes sexistes et racistes du
proviseur enregistré à son insu par une
élève qu'il recevait pour leur expliquer
les règles à respecter dans l'enceinte
scolaire c'est même surveillant ont donc
organisé devant le lycée aussi rejoint
par des collègues d'autres
établissements marseillais mais aussi
par quelques professeurs une
manifestation le 25 mai dernier pour
dire je cite leur opposition au contrôle
de signes religieux chez les élèves
c'est cela qui a entraîné le
licenciement la suspension par le
proviseur de surveillant et des
enseignante et un de ses licenciements
d'un AED a provoqué l'envahissement du
bureau du proviseur avec intimidation et
menace nous dit le journal le premier
juin dernier par des militants syndicaux
et d'extrême gauche ayant entraîné une
réaction du ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui a jugé cela inadmissible
alors qu'est-ce que vous vous en pensez
Yanis roder de ses affaires d'abaya qui
se multiplient la première chose que
j'en pense Myriam c'est d'abord
l'instrumentalisation de jeunes filles
depuis plusieurs mois en France dans le
but de contourner la loi de 2004 pour la
remettre en cause alors qu'elle protège
des pressions éveil à ce que la liberté
de conscience des mineurs soit préservée
la deuxième chose c'est la perte de
repère chez certains fonctionnaires qui
confondent conviction personnelle et
activités professionnelles quand on est
fonctionnaire on a le droit de ne pas
être d'accord avec la loi mais on a
sûrement pas le droit de protester
contre son application dans le cadre de
son travail la troisième chose Myriam
c'est que depuis le début de cette
affaire il y a comme le dit encore Le
Parisien une collusion de fait entre des
militants d'extrême gauche et des
Identitaires religieux pour qui la
question des tenues vestimentaires est
un véritable enjeu politique et
stratégique vous savez Myriam on parlait
pour les intellectuels qui furent
instrumentalisés par l'URSS d'idiot
utile terme également utilisé par le
philosophe et politique Pierre-André
tagieff quand l'extrême gauche fait le
jeu des islamistes et qui lui fit
d'ailleurs concevoir le terme
d'islamo-gauchisme merci pour ce parti
pris Yanis on verra ce qu'il en est par
la suite Thomas vous vouliez nous parler
du capitalisme mais plus plus
précisément du copinage entre
administrateur oui alors en effet Myriam
donc vous le savez toutes les grosses
boîtes on ce qu'on appelle un conseil
d'administration c'est un peu le comité
des vieux sages qui fixe le cap d'une
entreprise et dans notre beau pays on se
cote gaiement entre administrateur ami
camarades d'école et j'en passe et nous
avons un très bel exemple cette semaine
c'est Orange et BNP Paribas alors en
deux mots l'histoire orange souhaite
vendre sa filiale Orange Bank BNP
Paribas et candidate ça lui permettrait
de récupérer les deux millions de
clients d'Orange banques qui
s'ajouteraient donc aux 750 000 clients
de Hello Bank qui est une finale de BNP
par
le X c'est que le président du conseil
d'administration d'orange Jacques
aschenbroix est également administrateur
de BNP Paribas
ça fait des conflits d'intérêts non
exactement un gros risque de conflit
d'intérêt et d'ailleurs on peut même
s'interroger sur la pertinence de cette
vente la nouvelle DG d'orange elle veut
recentrer le groupe sur les télécoms et
donc la banque est moins prioritaire
pourquoi pas orange Bank fait des pertes
c'est vrai mais elle vise l'équilibre
d'ici deux ans donc c'est pas si loin et
par ailleurs toutes les banques en ligne
à part Fortuneo font des pertes pour
l'instant même le leader Boursorama
n'est pas encore rentable orange Bank
objectivement c'est un succès commercial
Dominion de clients c'est beaucoup plus
que hello Bank BforBank ou encore avec
sa banque et en plus c'est un peu le
pire moment pour vendre puisque les
marchés sont à la baisse depuis quelques
mois du coup dans ce contexte avoir en
plus un président du conseil
d'administration qui est également
administrateur chez BNP Paribas qui est
candidat hors achat ça ne fait que
renforcer les soupçons on est les seuls
en France à faire ce genre de cumul de
mandats non pas vraiment non alors si
par exemple on transposer la situation à
l'Italie un tel cas de figure serait
totalement impossible possible là-bas un
administrateur n'a pas le droit d'avoir
des mandats de même nature chez deux
concurrents dans le secteur de la banque
ou de l'assurance alors BNP Paribas
assure que Jacques ashion droit le
fameux se déporte entre guillemets cette
expression ça veut dire qu'en fait il
quitte la salle du conseil
d'administration quand on parle des
activités de banque en ligne type hello
Bank parce que c'est directement
concurrent de rangement mais est-ce que
ça suffit pour lever le doute et pour
réduire son influence vu son rôle dans
le conseil on peut en douter mais alors
est-ce qu'on a des raisons de progresser
d'espérer les Américains eux alors là
sont très très strictes compatibilité
les pays anglo-saxons sont beaucoup plus
carrée là-dessus alors ce mal français
du copinage entre dirigeants il existe
depuis très longtemps en 2010 on avait
un Michel pebreux qui cumulé quand même
6 mandats total AXA BNP Paribas
Saint-Gobain Lafarge et Arbus fini cette
époque là non cette époque est révolue
alors depuis la loi Macron de 2015 il y
a un maximum de trois mandats mais dans
tous les cas donc cette trajectoire est
la bonne et dans le business c'est
comment politique il faut dire non au
cumul des mandats très bien très bien
le point pour cette
chute il y a des lois à l'Assemblée pour
les politiques mais peut-être pas assez
en matière économique merci à vous les
affranchis Stéphanie des pierres à très
vite Yanis une nouvelle histoire d'école
quand vous voulez c'est la fin de cette
émission soirée documentaire à présent
qui commence avec Jean-Pierre Gratien à
demain même les mêmes heures
[Musique]